thank you
[Music]
guys ever thought about cyclists in a
way oh [__] them those makes you angry
yeah of course yep I kind of feel for
him though I kind of feel when I'm
riding a bicycle I hate myself yeah same
because like when you're riding a bike
on the street you realize like oh yeah
it is like me versus them in a lot of
ways because you didn't have to be
defensive but at the same time it's just
like pick a different hobby I mean
people barely look out for other cars
let alone that's what I'm saying
when I was in Miata I was practically on
a [__] Bike Dude
it's actually a [__] bike I feel like
um
the roads are kind of [__] up because
it's not really meant for anything else
but cars yeah like even it's not even
pedestrian friendly yeah okay
um so this is all Steve Dave presents
[__] bikers episode [__] yeah dude I
love all Steve Davis so here we go sick
[__] these bicycles 20 minutes ever JK
news has a hot take on bicyclists we
hate them here we go
oh wow that's not a regular bike is it
no
uh this is a handy pack car piece of
equipment and and what show me the rules
saying that you're left do this wait
what the [__]
he has a bicycle
it's a handicapped piece of equipment I
can't walk
you should have led with that
Class Act brother you're a Class Act
is she doing this oh my God I hope there
I hope they get eaten by a bear dude
they're getting on his [__] for using it
handicapped for being a handyman wow
crazy I'm telling you if if Hitler came
back and just wanted to kill the bikers
I think I'm in do you know what's funny
I when I see the guys that are on the
street and they're doing the ones with
the hands you always go that's pretty
[__] cool yeah and then as soon as
you see a cyclist you're like [__] those
guys
every time what's because someone's
making like something dope out of a bad
situation yeah the other person's just
choosing a bad life exactly right so he
said he was pissed off because that's
like not street legal for the trail he's
too heavy destroy the trail oh yeah what
a [__] idiot see the weird thing it's
gonna destroy the trail there's got to
be some kind of a correlation that just
makes shitty ass people with attitudes
like that want to ride bicycles yeah
there has to be there's some kind of car
some some sort of mental like the Venn
diagram you know what I mean like why do
they want to ride bicycles yeah because
they're not surfing I'll tell you that
because have you seen the video of them
like uh like a bunch of cyclists talking
[__] to like a cop that pulled them over
there's like tons of those videos really
where they're just like arguing with the
cops and the cops like what the [__] are
you talking about the cop is like is
getting so mad at these people because
they're like well I wasn't doing it like
according to city ordinances yeah
they're just being like that yes it
reminds you of the same soul that is in
the guy that films police Apartments
and he just stands there and the cops
have to come out and go bud what are you
doing what's your batch number and name
I'm good acting official business what I
this is like male Karen right yeah like
he decided to block him and tell him is
that street legal he didn't even he was
just like being addictive for no reason
he's just like hi you can't be here with
this even if you're a handy sorry and
her you should have left with that just
because you didn't hear him in the first
place yeah he did leave with that he did
leave with that yeah that's literally
what he said that's exactly and then
this [__]
wow dude like this video is [__]
kidding me this video pissed me off so
much I was like there's a lot of people
though that do act like this and before
the word Karen was whatever like they
they were always [__] there the HOA
people yeah but there was no name for
them there was it starts with the letter
F yeah 100
I didn't use that word anymore yeah
failures failures failures ends with f
and starts with the F ends with the S
failures
what do you think goes through these
people's minds because they do exist
right and the level of like entitlement
and they think they can be the cop of
the road and the ultimate Hall Monitor
yeah and then they they're just complete
[__] as if like you should know yeah
they have no I think they have no power
over anything yeah and the little things
like these little city ordinances give
them like a almost like a uh a platform
yeah kind of right because they remind
me of people that's never got their
asses handed to them yes for sure never
got the fight like everyone it's someone
that's gonna [__] their asses up this
guy just needs to get punched in the
[__] face one time and he'll just be
more chill yeah yeah no seriously
seriously he's probably yeah he's
definitely never been punched in the
face I feel like he's gonna learn
um how to do disarming and then like
carry a gun everywhere if he gets [__]
up yeah this guy probably hates concert
he's like nah I'm guns [__] kill
everybody but imagine you're just like
this like you're a handicapped dude
you're just trying to use this Trail
just like having a Scenic day or
whatever and then this guy this cyclist
gets in your way he's like are you
really you're really gonna do this [__]
[__] piece of [__] I wonder what
makes him have to express that yeah like
why can't you just mind your own [__]
business like what the [__] it sounds
like they think it's so weird they're
like they think that the wheelchair
guy's an [__] yeah no the ladies
literally yeah
they think he's entitled
what does it matter at that point yeah
right well you're the [__] idiot
that's asking you don't just go like
holy [__] I'm sorry dude the fact that
he the fact that he responded can't be
wrong and his response made sense it
really is the feeling of like they want
the illusion that they care about the
trail but really they care about being
right they just want to be a bully
that's what cyclists do they get in
their little [__] bikes and they take
over the whole Road and like this is
this is a cycling Lane that's what I'm
saying how the [__] did that connect
perfectly like the circles overlapped
but they're mountain bikers though yeah
that's that's even more upsetting right
because on on those Trails it's like I
would imagine there's a little bit of a
community over there right you're riding
like hey great Trails today or whatever
the [__] like whatever you say to each
other I don't know that's what you would
say do you think they're on their bikes
and like
I think there's been a wheelchair in
this [__] Trail this feels a little
loose
I'm like slipping on the [__] Trail
what the [__] the mountain biking
Community is pretty is pretty cool right
but when you go to bike parks and all
that it's different but there are
[__] [__] like this on like
off-road trails where people are walking
and they feel entitled and pissed
because people are walking on the trails
yeah but it's meant for pedestrians yeah
if you're dressed like this though with
a Captain America you're not sure that's
off brand Capital yeah I don't even know
what that is it looks like a pinball
bumper
the thing it's not even about cycling
anymore it's like in any place time in
whatever activity they're acting like
this yeah yeah definitely I remember um
so I was at the bike park
I wiped out on the trail and then like I
was trying to get back up and then this
dumbass [__] passed me by and goes you
can't block the trail go [__] yourself
no [__] you dumbass and I'm like
it reminds me I'm on the [__] ground
wiping out with the it's like and then I
got branches in my hair like park with
ramps and jumps and like people are
gonna fall have you seen those videos
that were like you can't park here and
somebody who just got into an accident
their car's all [__] up hey you can't
park here I just got in a [__]
accident also mind your own business is
so funny
dumbass dude I was at you know I was in
Santa Barbara a couple months uh years
ago it's two years ago
and he sees these so there's like
college kids who moved into the
neighborhood like and they're all
sharing a house renting it right so he's
looking for any [__] excuse in the
world to just [__] on them because they
shouldn't be in this neighborhood
they're too young and they play music or
whatever they Splash in their pool too
loud
so then he sees that they parked in
front of his house and he's like he I'd
never seen him come alive yeah he was
like [__] excited because he had
something
and he's gotten dead to rights this time
because they parked in front of his
house and like you can't park in front
of his house but like you can obviously
parking lot but on his block not on his
block but I'm like what oh man what
pisses you off so much they just parked
like outside on the street it's
completely fine no they're not blocking
his driving they're not blocking the
driveway it's illegal they're just
completely legal and he's just like they
should they just shouldn't do it and I'm
like what did he want to go there and
tell him something he did he go he went
to their house and told him not to park
on his [__] in front of his house but
like why old man because that's his
[__] curve dude that's what I'm
saying that's his curve that's where he
puts his trash cans every time I see him
now I'm like I got these [__] kids
parking in front of my house
and then he knows I'm making fun of him
too
[Laughter]
these kids are parking for my house and
like yeah it's legal but like I'm not
trying to look out my window and see
like the birds and stuff like that and
like what the [__] is this I've always
found that room really really weird
because people swear like it's a real
rule yeah but I don't think it exists
anywhere unless it's no sometimes that
HOA can try to enforce it you're not
supposed to park on your whatever but
that's like within like an actual like
gated community or some shame right yeah
unfortunately because that would happen
outside of uh where I lived in Hollywood
the guy would leave a note every time I
did it and if I was like three houses
down randomly he would leave a note and
be like hey there's not enough parking
for all of us so can you please not Park
here that doesn't mean anything yeah and
you do this that's not a rule bro I
think all those Karen's they're what
where they're stupid is they think
everybody has the same idea of like
common courtesy and sense as they do so
then they're just pissed because they're
like oh you're doing this too you're
doing it to me it's only in the favor of
themselves and nobody else like they're
not thinking about everybody it was
actually a Karen long time ago at
barbell and no one knew who this [__]
member was and then she she was uh I
guess on a squat rack or whatever and
then you know how there's the glass the
mirrors and then on the back there's
like the dumbbells so I went past
grabbed some dumbbells went past started
working out
but then she like turned around she goes
you could even wait till my set was done
and then this and that and then she was
like going off on me and I was like
who are you mad and I was like me and
I'm like what did you walk in front of a
camera or something no there was no
camera because people people get that's
the thing that people get pissed for
them no camera she's not even my [__]
ass she's not even a power lifter she
looked like a [__] mom with yoga
pants on I was just like
so shocked and I think I told like the
front desk like who is that lady they're
like oh she just started working out
here recently and I'm all like that is
the most weirdest because it's not even
the culture yeah yeah but she was just
like pissed and that caring that energy
and I was just like what are you talking
about this is so [__] weird yeah
something like that what do you do you
kick him out
the lady yeah
no he would have asked him like what
would we're trying to level with them
what's going on like and then if it is
actually a problem we'll try to try to
solve it but we try to like get to the
bottom of it and usually when you ask a
few more questions oh you know it's just
had a bad days came in here or whatever
and yeah I actually really like Joe I'm
actually a big fan of Joe and like you
know that's usually what happens a
couple more questions and then it's just
them taking it out on something that
just happened has nothing to do with it
have you had any of the influencer
chicks come in and try to do butt shots
and stuff like that and had to be like
yo what the [__]
um oh that's a whole new thing where
they try to catch somebody checking them
out and they try to blow their own
channel up that way we've had a whole
brand come in and shoot content and uh
they're obviously not they don't know
how to use our equipment and it was
funny seeing them trying to figure out
how to use it there was one where it was
like um so we have like these uh these
tires in the back where you lift them
when you push them over and then so
there's like these like four like like
super hot chicks but they look like they
never lifted but it's for Fitness brand
and then the director was like yeah I
just have the tire like that and then
everyone just kind of hold it like this
and that's not how you would ever use it
so you have all these like like just
chicks just holding these tires like
trying to be thirst straps and then
we're all like looking like
that's not even how like you it's like
going on a bench like a flat bench and
then like like hugging it this way you
know it's like we're just like what the
[__] is going on I like that a tire
company is probably looking at you going
that's not how you use a tire
foreign